تتزايد اهميه الطاقه المتجدده عالميا
واوروبيا خصوصا بعد حرب روسيا على
اوكرانيا التي صرعت عمليه الانتقال
الطاقوي التي ترمي لزياده حصه الطاقه
المتجدده وتقرير الاعتماد على مصادر
الطاقه الاحفوريه
وبحسب مفاوضه الطاقه الاوروبيه فان العام
الماضي شهد ولاول مره توليد الكهرباء من
الطاقه المتجدده باكثر مما يتم انتاجه من
خلال الغاز
فبريطانيا على سبيل المثال اصبحت فيها
طاقه الرياح ثانيه اكبر مصدر لانتاج
الكهرباء بنحو 27% مقابل
38% للغاز الطبيعي اما اوروبيا فتولد طاقه
الرياح نحو 17% من حاجه القاره للكهرباء
وتنقسم طاقه الرياح الى بريه وبحريه ولا
تشكل الاخيره سوى اثني عشر في المئه من
اجمالي طاقه الرياح
وطاقه الرياح من اكثر مصادر الطاقه تفضيلا
حيث قدرتها على الاستمرار في انتاج الطاقه
على مدار العام تقريبا لكن هذا النوع من
مصادر الطاقه خاصه ما يعرف بمزارع الرياح
البحريه يواجه تحديات تهدد نموها على
راسها التضخم وارتفاع كلف الانتاج وهو ما
يهدد بوقف بعض المشاريع القائمه والغاء
اخرى
لكن تنافسيه طاقه الرياح البحريه تظل
محدوده اذ تقدر كلفه انتاج الكهرباء من
هذا المصدر بخمسه وسبعين دولارا لكل ميجا
واتساب في حين تبلغ التكلفه نحو 33 دولارا
من طاقه الرياح البريه بينما تصل الى اكثر
من 48 دولارا لكل ميجا واتساعه للكهرباء
والمولده من الطاقه الشمسيه
ورغم تنامي الطلب على الطاقه الرياح الا
ان مختصين حذروا من ان مشاريع طاقه الرياح
البحريه اصبحت مهدده اكثر من اي وقت مضى
خصوصا بعد جائحه كورونا وتعطل سلاسل
الامدادات فضلا عن التضخم العالمي ورفع
اسعار الفائده فتنامي كلا في الاستثمار
ادى الى تاخير عشره مشاريع قائمه بقيمه 33
مليار دولار في الولايات المتحده واوروبا
وهي نفس التحديات التي واجهت على سبيل
المثال شركه فاتن فولا السويديه التي الغت
خططا لانشاء محطه رياح قباله الساحل
البريطاني بسبب ارتفاع تكلفه بناء مزارع
الرياح البحريه بنسبه 40% هذا العام